it may be easy to lie on the internet
but it's also very easy to spot one all
it takes is a quick search or glance at
Wikipedia and you can uncover the truth
but don't let this fool you lazy sloppy
lies are everywhere and they give you a
false sense of confidence well-crafted
careful lies also roam your Facebook
feed they're just too sneaky to get
detected you'll never notice them and
that's what makes them so good what's
special about these lies isn't how
convincing or widespread they are but
how they're actually designed to become
true in theory each new site works
independently going out gathering data
and writing stories based on what they
find sites may disagree but each is a
vote for one version of the truth
letting us read several and think
critically finding commonalities
discrepancies and ultimately the likely
truth some companies still do this but
not nearly enough real reporting is
really expensive there are travel legal
equipment and licensing costs and it all
takes a very long time even after all
that work there's still no guarantee
anything will materialize if a story
turns out to be inaccurate or
uninteresting a good journalist has to
abandon it and tens of thousands of
dollars are flushed down the drain but
if the goal is to make money and it
usually is there's a far easier way
instead of spending weeks gathering
primary sources journalists can turn
what's already available into four or
five articles a day even a well-meaning
respectable writer at one of these
companies will soon realize that it's
either this or no food on the table this
is where lists reaction pieces and cheap
summaries come from
there's simply no time for primary
sources so journalists write articles
about articles this kind of cheap
watered-down content isn't just annoying
to see the effect it has on the truth is
absolutely disastrous no longer is each
source a filter through which
information is checked and researched
but simply an echo of other sources
think of it like herd immunity if enough
people are resistant to a disease it's
very hard to spread even to the
especially vulnerable when every site
thoroughly researches its articles a lie
can sneak by once
wurst but when site sir is susceptible
as they are now and there's this much
sharing between sites lies spread
incredibly fast an honest mistake in one
article quickly becomes a lie and many
as journalists desperately repost and
spread what they see the onion has been
mistaken for real news and simple typos
have created widespread misconceptions
but that's just on accident when lies
are manufactured it's much much worse
what makes something true on the
Internet are the number and quality of
sources so a good liar actually sources
their fake story Photoshop image or
made-up fact and so effectively that
it's indistinguishable from the truth
and because online journalism is so
connected all it takes is one desperate
writer for a lie to enter the cycle and
everything else follows and as I'm sure
you're aware there are many desperate
writers the line might be emailed to a
writer whose short of their daily
article quota just the gift they need
and not one they have time to question
this may work but it also might fall
apart if people do some digging a more
effective method is called circular
sourcing whether they admit it or not
journalists use Wikipedia too even if
only as a starting place so you begin by
editing Wikipedia with the lie and then
wait someone will probably spot and
remove it but it only takes one
journalist to see at first a bit of
negligence or mixing up of sources and
the lie will make it into their article
if you're lucky they might even
mistakenly cite it if this sounds
unlikely remember they often have
minutes not hours to write an article
and their job depends on it so now you
go back to Wikipedia but this time with
a source that same article you just
tricked more people will find it more
will be written and more sources created
each website will cite another in a big
circle of misinformation the big
reputable sites won't pick it up at
first but over time it'll travel up the
stream first on a blog then a local news
site then a larger one and so on this is
how truth can be manufactured on the
Internet all it takes is one unsourced
Wikipedia edit and it becomes common
knowledge the foundations of online
journalism are so shaky that is
there's still money in this kind of
watered-down content people will
continue exploiting it we don't even
really know how often it happens all we
have are the reports of people who admit
to having done it and these stories are
often more profitable than the Articles
they describe so who knows maybe they
too are lies when an idea for a project
pops into my head I've always gone
straight to YouTube to learn how to make
it maybe I want to learn some specific
software so I spend forever finding a
decent channel and then realize they're
using the 2013 version of that program
and I've already lost momentum so I've
started using Skillshare a website and
mobile app with full video classes on
specific software and skill topics the
idea is that because classes are curated
and the teachers are actually paid
they're really incentivized to create
high-quality courses you can ask
questions download videos and track your
progress I often have a specific problem
or question with a program I'm using and
I can just jump straight to the
corresponding video to find a solution
on Skillshare it's really handy the
first 300 people to use this link will
get two months to see if they like it
completely free go and search for
something you're interested in whether
it be video editing creative writing or
programming and just give it a try it
helps support this channel and if you
don't like it you can just leave thanks
to Skillshare for sponsoring this video
[Music]